[Music]
my name is Megan O'Keefe I'm Sandeep
Parikh and we are here to talk to you
all about how we deal with problems in
this do when things inevitably go wrong
we're super excited today to mostly do
demos in this session the first thing
I'm going to do just to queue up Sandip
demos is give a bit of background about
why SEO can be difficult and what we're
really here today to talk about this
slide may be familiar to a lot of you
when you move from a sort of monolithic
application into microservices a lot of
challenges can arise when you start
decoupling your code into maybe
different languages and frameworks and
different services it can be tough to
keep track of everything things like
service discovery all of a sudden you
have lots of Network calls that you may
not have had before
this can cause congestion and the
network reliability so you inevitably
with the complexity of Micra services
there's more things to keep track of and
things inevitably go down security you
now have more points of entry into the
application instead of one firewall rule
you might have many and finally
aggregating metrics and logs so you need
kind of a way to sort of bring all of
the information about your services
together ideally into something like a
single point pane of glass and while
kubernetes addresses some of the scaling
and life cycling challenges of micro
services and is an incredibly powerful
piece of technology it doesn't solve all
those problems right so with the goal
the goal of isseo is to help unify micro
services and the way that you manage
them through an additional set of
platform to give a review of what SEO
provides and some of the things we'll be
diving into today it's a somewhat
complex architecture in which there are
multiple control plane components
managing a set of envoy proxies so at
the bottom there we have the control
plane consists of pilot mixer galley
citadel which handle let's see traffic
management telemetry policy
config ingestion and certs and keys
respectively we will go into the some of
the specifics today and then up there at
the top we have the Envoy proxies these
comprise the data plane these are the
things that we are configuring via the
sto control plane and what does this do
get you helps address some of this
complexity challenge right unified
traffic management centralized policy
checks telemetry ingestion custom
adapters for the vlogs and metrics
system of your choice and automated
service identity so that with SEO you
can turn on mutual TLS and to end
service encryption with a single policy
but raise your hand if you have tried to
bring a CEO into production at your
organization yeah keep your hand up if
it has been a challenge yeah sto is
still a somewhat new piece of technology
it's gone through some changes
released 1.1 a couple of weeks ago and
there are some challenges when adopting
sto a special top of kubernetes and the
first is that with those multiple
control plan components that I showed in
that diagram there's just a lot going on
all of the pieces kind of fit together
and generate a lot of logs the API is
that sto exposes our broad and complex
and highly configurable there are many
many ways to configure a virtual service
in this do and this can get challenging
when something goes wrong because you're
like is this even a valid virtual
service for instance there's a lot of
paths to a failing state and we're here
today to demo some of those paths yeah
so the other thing we want to stress is
that were as developer relations for
Google we really want to know how folks
are using sto and where are the gaps in
the tooling and in the ecosystem so that
we can help try to address that at
Google and out in the broader community
so we did want to mention that you'll
see us using things like curl throughout
this demo and if you've used SEO you may
also just be kind of stuck in this loop
of just repeatedly curling
things go wrong and we acknowledge that
as well so without further ado we're
going to go into three hands-on demos
today my colleague here is going to
handle the first couple addressing
traffic management and telemetry and I
will be picking up again in a little
while to cover authentication take it
away cool thanks Megan so we're gonna
start around traffic management so how
do you debug SEO traffic routing so as a
quick recap the way pilot works right
you take your virtual service rules your
gateway rules or policies you push them
up to the control plane pilot make sure
those rules get pushed out to all the
Envoy proxies and there's there are
mechanisms built in to figure out our by
Envoy proxies in sync with the pilot
rules that were sent to the cluster and
what are those differences and we can
see and examine the configuration on
both sides of that so the traffic API
and this is just a small subset of it we
couldn't really go through all of it
here but just as again a quick recap
there's this idea of sort of north-south
right inbound and outbound traffic into
it out of your your service mesh and
then there's east-west traffic which is
in and out traffic within the service
mesh itself so north and south our
gateway and service entry respectively
and then within a cluster or within a
service measure I should say the
east-west is virtual service and
destination rule so those are the
objects that we use to configure things
like traffic splitting traffic steering
or ingress or egress so the demo app
we're going to use today is well
actually how many of you have used book
info from the SDO samples repo there
that's almost everybody perfect well we
wanted to create another little version
of it so I made something called weather
info that we're gonna use here it's a
simple front end with two backends
nothing terribly complicated but it lets
us comb through the logs a little bit
easier because it's a smaller
application so this is what the UI looks
like it just shows you the weather
either in with v1 it shows you the
weather in a single city and a v2 it
shows you the weather in multiple cities
right that's all this thing does it's
got an outbound API call to a weather
API service so we've got that server
country as well for that
so the problem that we're having with
this deployment though is that we push
this this code up we pushed our virtual
service rules everything is is out there
in the service mesh but what we're
seeing is 50/50 splits of traffic not
the 90/10 we've specified and for those
of you that are familiar with with doing
the certain kubernetes when you deploy
things by default you get this kind of
50/50 round-robin routing right you're
not getting any kind of particular split
unless you've got different ratios of
pods out there in our case we've got one
of each one of v2 and one of v1 but
we're still seeing 50/50 we're not
seeing again that 90/10 split so the way
this was deployed and I just want to do
this instead of showing you guys more
yellow at the moment but the way it's
deployed is if configured ingress
gateway with a gateway policy and a
virtual service to direct inbound
traffic to the weather front-end weather
front-end then has a destination rule
and a virtual service that splits the
traffic 90/10 and then we've got one
service entry for that weather API call
so with that can we switch to this
laptop demo ok can you guys read that ok
yeah all right so let's just take a
quick look at what's deployed in this
cluster so this was a GK cluster with
the sto add-on it's set to permissive
mode deployed out there and I can show
you the pods that are in there as well
so that's the first place we're gonna
look we're gonna look at the pods we've
got running so right weather front-end
is working fine and so are the weather
the two weather back-end versions as
well let's check the services and make
sure those are actually set up correctly
as well so we could see the weather
backend service is also configured
correctly and then we can actually dig
into the objects that we pushed up
earlier so I can say coops ETL get
virtual service and there's a virtual
service for weather backend and that's
the one that directs traffic from the
front end through that 90/10 split so we
can actually look at that in depth
and so this dumps out a little bit extra
output but here we can see that the host
that we're trying to identify here
whether back end and we've got a
destination and route here with 90% and
10% down here so again this should be
working but if we take a look at the UI
and I'll just hit refresh a couple times
here I pulled this up a little bit
earlier it's roughly showing us about a
50/50 split right again we should be
seeing a lot more of this single version
which is just a single city in this case
so let me flip back and the next thing
I'm gonna do again minions this code or
troubleshooting mode you have a lot of
steps to choose from and try to do it in
sort of an orderly fashion but you know
Megan and I were talking about this
earlier it's sort of a cyclical process
right you end up kind of going back
through again and again but the steps
I'd sort of like to take here are the
first things aren't one just checking
the basics did my pods and services get
up there correctly are all the SEO
policies I pushed running correctly in
my convertible service destination rule
etc so those are all in there and those
are those look fine so we've got a dig a
level deeper so the first thing I'm
gonna do here is make sure that within
the cluster itself we're not seeing the
routing right maybe the problem is
whether front-end maybe if I try another
service that's inside the cluster and
inside the service mesh we might see
different behavior so if you remember
there was a pod there earlier called
recipe that's a little utility that
Meghan rope just to check response you
know compare response types so I'm
quickly going to execute a command
inside that container and I got it here
somewhere
never type live alright so what this is
gonna do it's gonna issue a thousand
quick quick quick requests to the
weather back-end service and a little
endpoint that we create a call version
just to compare response types and again
even within the service mesh inside the
cluster itself we're still seeing 5050
so the problem is somewhere else in the
stack so one of the things we like to do
next is check the check the Envoy proxy
from the outbound side so in this case
we can look at the weather front-end
envoy proxy log and see if anything
shows up in there the first thing I'll
do is grab the front-end pod
all right so we're gonna use that front
end of a whole bunch later on here so
first thing we need to do is get the
logs from the Envoy proxy from that from
that pod oh thanks
see this is why you should never do it
live all right so that's a lot of log
detail but we can actually start to dig
in here and see what's going on and see
a whole bunch of inbound calls we're
actually looking for a pond so I'm gonna
quickly grep here for outbound it's a
little bit easier to read so we can see
outbound calls from weather front end to
weather back end and something that
you'll start to get used to looking at
and understanding when you look at the
Envoy logs is this this whole line here
what's saying I'm trying to make an app
on call on port 5,000 to weather
back-end but you'll notice there's a
little extra gap there between those two
those two those two pipes
well what that's telling us is it's not
directing the traffic to a particular
version right it's just sending it the
traffic out to weather back-end and
again we're falling back to kubernetes
round-robin routing it's not using the
FCO service mesh routing that we set up
so now it starts to get a little more
interesting this is where you're gonna
start digging into the is do control
proxy configuration commands so SEO
control is a binary that we ship with
the ischial release itself and so then
actually has a ton of useful debugging
commands and I'm gonna scroll up a
little bit here but it's it's a great
powerful tool to really dig into how the
proxy is configured and how things are
set up so here we're actually gonna use
things like proxy status and proxy
config to dig into where the problem is
and try to understand a little bit
better so the first thing I'm going to
do is check the proxy status and so we
can see that for
all of our proxies and the ones we care
about are in the default namespace of
whether back-end multiple single in
front-end and those are all synced right
all those rules are current and synced
and they're getting them from this
particular pilot pod and we can actually
check a we can check the weather
front-end one in specifically you always
have to specify the pod name and the
namespace oops and so here what we'll
see again the cluster configurations
match the listeners match in the routes
match so what that's telling us is that
again the Envoy proxy knows everything
that pilot knows so the rules we push
the pilot they have made their way over
to the Envoy proxy running in weather
front-end but we still haven't figured
out what the problem is
so how do we again continue to dig
further and that's where the proxy
config and comes in so proxy config on
front-end will show us a little bit more
detail and we here there's a couple of
sub commands here so you want to check
the first two cluster configuration on
the front-end pod and what this will
tell us is all of the these sort of
outbound components that it can send
things to are inbound
inbound services they can send
information to so again we see here
we've got weather back end with no
version information and it knows that it
can send things to multiple and single
but the question is why is it not
happening so looks like again the
configurations have made their way
across well let's check one more
component which is the outbound routes
from that Envoy proxy because that could
be another issue
so again if Co control proxy config on
the front-end pod and we're gonna look
at the routes so these routes are just
based on port name and so we see that
there are a bunch of series of routes
just for individual different services
running inside the service mesh in
particular our weather back-end is
running on port 5,000 so let's take a
look at that one in depth here
all right so we can see that one
specifically and it's only got one
virtual host so that right there tells
us there might be a problem right
because we actually have two hosts there
we've got weather back-end running in
the v1 and the v2 configuration so we
should have more than one virtual host
outbound so let's take a look at that
one and actually you can output that as
JSON now I'm gonna do this the first
time just so you can see the output cuz
it's lengthy this is a lot to go through
it's lots of the kind of scroll up and
and try to read through so often what I
will do in these scenarios is actually
filter this using a tool called JQ which
just helps you parse through JSON and
I'm actually gonna filter it down to a
particular set of things I need to look
at hopefully that works all right so
it's showing us all of the outbound
services it knows about on port 5,000
and here's the problem right there is
actually no route for this Envoy proxy
to send traffic to weather backend it
only knows about sending traffic back to
itself because this service the front
end service is also running on four or
five thousand well so what's the problem
right how do we figure out from here
again we know the rules have made it all
the way across but there's actually no
entry in the route table for that proxy
to send traffic to whether back-end well
as it turns out there are two things you
need to do to make sure your services
become part of the service mesh the
first one is obviously adding the
sidecar proxy all right so you deploy
your pod you get the or you get that
sidecar injected automatically in your
pod and that makes it part of the mesh
there's actually another sort of
esoteric requirement that you have to
worry about as well which is in your
service definition right so remember
I've got weather back-end it's got two
versions so in my deployment I had two
deployments weather backends single
weather back in multiple and I have one
kubernetes service fronting them in that
service definition you have to use a
very specific naming convention for your
port right if you just use back-end it
doesn't work if you use you know come up
with the name doesn't work you actually
have to specify two parts the protocol
type so in our case HTTP
and then any kind of optional
identifiers and so we can actually take
a look at this service real quickly and
we can see that that is the problem
itself right so here in my service
definition that's the issue right if
that requirement is not met that pod
doesn't get picked up inside the mesh so
let's go ahead and I'm gonna copy and
paste this really quickly from my notes
so let's go ahead and apply that updated
service and so you can see here what I
did was all I'm changing is that one
little port at the bottom I changed the
name to HTTP
- back-end so I'm gonna go ahead and
commit that and in a couple of seconds
you could actually tail through some of
the Envoy logs and see new things start
to pop up and happen but we can actually
just go right back to SEO control and
check that same command earlier where we
checked all the outbound routes and we
filtered them down by name and domain
and now we see that whether back-end is
a specific available outbound route and
if we actually look at that JQ output
fully again I apologize I'm gonna have
to scroll a little bit here just to show
you all this this really really
compelling stuff there's actually two
entries in this configuration there's an
entry for multiple which is one of the
versions and there's an entry for single
that means now it knows that on port
5,000 there's two routes there's one for
front-end there's one for back-end and
inside that 5,000 route for back-end
there are actually multiple entries and
multiple subsets it can direct traffic
to now I'm gonna go and rerun my recipe
command and just to see if we get a
difference in version output here after
a thousand requests it's pretty close
well looks like there was one little
error along the way there but we got
about a 90/10 split between our services
so that right there we were able to
again figure this out now what I would
say is the solution to this problem
turns out as relatively trivial and if
you dig through the documentation this
requirement is really well laid out or
at least it's reasonably well laid out
and that you have to use the correct
naming convention but the purpose of
this demo was really to show the SEO
control binary that mechanism is a great
debugging tool you still need to have
some other things in your toolbox like
curl or even again JQ or grep to filter
through the output because it is quite
lengthy but if Co control gives you a
lot of visibility into the different
levels and the different states of
configuration between again the control
plane and the data plane so we could
switch back to the slides for a second
all right back in video there just in
case so that was the traffic version so
for the next demo what I want to do is
take a quick walkthrough on debugging
telemetry and so again just a quick
recap on the way mixer works right those
Envoy proxy that is - a proxy that sits
there inside of your inside of your pod
right next to your container is sending
telemetry and metrics information to
mixer which is a control plane component
mixer then forwards that information on
to the backend of your choice in this
case it could be for me Thea stack
driver data dog you name it the problem
is that the mixer configuration is
hilariously complicated there's a lot of
stuff so again our issue here is that
we've got custom metrics that aren't
showing up in Prometheus how do we
figure out what that problem is or how
do we fix that problem so let me just
jump over here back to the demo please
and I'm going to switch to my other two
cluster and this has got a similar
deployment setup already the only
difference is I have a little no
generator script that's running just to
generate some load so the first thing I
want to do is take a quick look at
prometheus running inside this cluster
so here's the prometheus entry and I
have these metrics in there that just
automatically dump out the temperature
of my of the cities I mean when it finds
them so I can actually start to look
through here and look and I'm not seeing
in my metrics so right we know that
there's that's the problem there but the
quick thing we can do is check the
service discovery component and see can
we find our pods in here and if you look
we've got 0 to 99 active targets up
there that means for me this is not
picking up any metrics from our pods all
right it's getting the metrics out of
the isseo proxy but nothing in
particular from my applications or my
services so we know that something's
missing
on our end because if we actually open
this up and dig around I'm just gonna
show this relatively quickly alright so
I think that's probably somewhat
challenging to read and make it a little
bigger so here's the weather backend
whoops here's the weather backend rule
and we can see that it's getting dropped
right it's not picking anything up
because it's not publishing anything and
that's the solution in this case is I'm
actually not telling Prometheus how to
scrape the metrics out of my out of my
container out of my service container
itself so the easiest way to do that is
to add some annotations and I've
actually got a canned version of this
here that I can show you very quickly
and so here's the bid I need to add
right down there inside each of my
deployments I need to make sure I
specify a particular set of annotations
so that Prometheus will scrape the
metrics and then include them with the
rest of the sto metrics that it's
automatically pulling in by default so I
can quickly apply this new configuration
and then what will happen at a matter of
a few seconds or minutes or so is that
it'll start to see those metrics come in
we can actually take one more quick look
at Prometheus and see if that's working
though so I'm gonna refresh this page
and what you'll see is inside of this
this target is to have secured it's
actually got two new services that it's
picking up which are the two die just
annotated and if we go back to the graph
we can actually start looking for city
temperatures that's the custom metric
I'm outputting we can execute a graph
there so it's only got one so far but
it's starting to pick it up now the
other components of mix are though right
there's a lot of other individual kind
of configuration there that you might
need to look at so one of the ways you
can do that is using coops ETL commands
and if you actually pull all of the API
resources and grep with just iste ió you
can see there's quite a bit of custom
resource definitions that we supply or
that a CEO supplies so digging through
this by default or by you know just as a
kind of a debugging step is a little bit
challenging so there's a great set of
Doc's
on the SEO iope age and I want to
mention called there's inside the f8
inside help FAQ there's a great page
called missing metrics and what it does
is it literally walks you through every
possible sort of debug step of mixer now
the challenge is that a lot of these
mixer components are very tightly
coupled so if there's a broken free
configuration somewhere where maybe a
rule is not there or maybe some of the
metrics aren't there or maybe it's not
sending information correctly one of the
easiest steps to kind of get things back
up and running is to just reapply the
mixer configuration and fill in any gaps
that may have occurred
so we could switch back to the slides
I'm going to show a quick example of
what that looks like so what you end up
doing for mixer debugging is confirming
the report calls right and that's where
you connect to one of the if Co
telemetry pods and take a look at its UI
you can actually curl against the
current metrics extending out to
Prometheus and it actually has a bunch
of diagnostics in there so you can check
those calls and you could also look at
just individual configuration problems
or handlers or logs themselves for the
handlers it just depends on what your
outbound mixer config looks like if your
configured for stackdriver you want to
see stracke driver handlers and adapters
if you have Prometheus and Griffin oh
you want to see Prometheus rules in
there if you're looking at some of the
metrics you want to make sure that the
metrics for like you know request count
TCP request size bytes etc those are in
there but again if something is missing
it's very hard to pick out one component
and reapply it so one of the things I
often end up doing is pulling down the
latest release of Sto in this case I use
the helm chart i generate the helm chart
for the full install with mixer on and
mixer off I take the diff of those two
and then I take that little bit that's
left over well not little it's still
relatively long and then I push that
config back up to the cluster so I'm
basically filling in anything that might
have been missing any missing metrics
definitions any missing rules that kind
of configuration kick will will solve
that problem it's not a great solution
at the moment but for kind of a weird
set of issues that might be your best
bet now I think if there are individual
like metric handler things missing you
might be able to again extract the
little parts of the configuration but
because there's so many C RDS and it's
very tightly coupled it's hard to pick
and choose sometimes it's easier just to
reapply and make sure it's filling in
whatever's missing with that I'm going
to hand it off back to Meghan to talk
about security
awesome alright so I know it's kind of a
whole bunch of demos and I'm here to do
one last one all about authentication so
I kind of had to choose one security
demo to do so SEO supports both
authentication and authorization so sto
supports end user authentication with
JWT tokens as well as service to service
authentication and TLS as well as
kubernetes are back so I had to kind of
choose one and I chose M TLS
authentication how does it work I'm
going to give a quick recap before I
dive into the demo about what we should
expect to be seeing when we turn on an
TLS mutual TLS authentication for one
service the first thing that happens in
the data plane is a TLS handshake so an
exchanging of certs and keys from
service 8 to service B then service a
does a secure naming check and what this
means is that sto has a mechanism to
ensure that a client-side service can
make sure that the server-side service
is authorized to be running it and what
this actually means is a comparison of
the service account against the actual
pod that's running making sure it's the
real service B and finally there is a
TLS connection that is established what
is the actual ISTE o architecture that
makes this happen so there's two control
plane components involved in stom TLS
the first is Citadel said the Dell is
responsible for generating the certs and
keys for each of the sidecar enabled
services and what Citadel will do is
generate a cert key pair for the service
account in kubernetes so in my case
today it's just the default service
account and then when you enable sidecar
injection as I have today for my entire
default namespace on my gke cluster when
the new pod is spawned in GK kubernetes
will mount that cert key pair that said
that I'll created as a secret or sorry
it's a secret kubernetes and kubernetes
mounts it into the pod so whether or not
you've enabled M TLS the cert key pair
is there what this means is that when
you the user does
side that you want to enforce strict em
TLS for a service a namespace or the
entire mesh you can do so and it happens
very quickly so what you would do as the
user is create a policy an sto policy
API object add it to the kubernetes api
server through coop CTL and pilot intern
is watching the kubernetes api server
and creates an envoy filter and pushes
that down so it's a multi-step process
and we're here today to talk about when
this thing does not go right so in this
demo i will be using the same sample app
of weather info and i want to enforce
them TLS for only the weather backend so
this is the y Emmel that you would apply
to make this work
it's an steal policy object and you can
see there at the bottom it says peers
and TLS and i know the syntax is a bit
weird it was designed to grow in case we
support more things later so it's just M
TLS Open bracket so in this demo I will
be showing the following things so for
simplicity purposes I only have one
version of the backend that I'm sending
traffic to the multiple version and what
I want to see is turning on them TLS for
the backend and seeing a nice 200 happen
between front end and back end
but when I'm seeing instead is a 503 so
let's walk through that demo so if we
can switch to my terminal please I know
we've had some some glitchy issues that
are sort of black mirror esque on the
screen here and I apologize for that but
uh alright so here I am in my terminal
I'm not as brave I'm not going to be
typing out every single command so bear
with me as I go into vs code and copy
paste some commands here all right so
like in the previous demos I'm in the
cluster with the weather info app
deployed I already have sto installed on
this cluster but I do not have any MTL s
policies enabled so if I run coop CTL
get policies I can see there's nothing
there quite yet you can see here in two
out of two what that means is that
there's two containers per pod I have
turned on a co sidecar and Jack
for my default namespace so if I try to
go to my weather front done now I can
refresh the page this is the ingre SEO
ingress gateway external IP through
which I've exposed the front and only
multiple showing up just to clarify
exactly why that is I literally went
into some noobs virtual service and I'm
sending every all traffic to the
multiple version so if we go into the
sto documentation on authentication if
you've ever been to this page it's a bit
long but has a ton of useful information
what it says here if we scroll down to
authentication policies but if you want
to enable clients have authentication
rules with mutual TLS you need both a
policy and a destination rule and just
straight off the bat that can be tricky
right you're like oh I just need like a
policy just like a naval and TLS but
what this actually means is that if you
have a destination rule you might need
to actually change it to enforce em TLS
and the reason for this so if I go into
the policy I'm about to enforce the
reason you need two resources is because
the policy is what tells the weather
backend to receive TLS traffic but the
destination rule is what tells the
clients of the weather backend to use
TLS so mutual means both right so what
we're going to do is apply these
resources to the cluster and hope for
the best and I know yesterday I used a
lot of shell aliases so I'm not going to
do that today
MPLS back-end one is the file that I'm
about to apply and you can see here that
we created that policy and that
destination rule for weather back-end so
what I hope to see here if I keep
refreshing the page is that what we
might start to see are some 503 errors
and it can take a couple of seconds to
start to propagate down but what we will
eventually see within five or ten
seconds is that all the connections
between the weather front end and the
weather back end are 503 and if you use
s you raise your hand if you've seen
this upstream connector
yes this is the sort of classic envoy as
something's wrong error and this is what
the back end is reporting and we're
displaying it on the front end okay how
do we figure out what's going wrong so I
have a couple of things I like to do
it's somewhat personal in the way you
want to kind of look at logs and try to
parse everything what I like to do in
this case where I only have kind of two
services going on is to just look at the
logs so here on the left I'm showing the
weather front-end logs here on the right
I'm showing the weather back-end logs
the actual tool I'm using here is called
Stern it's an open source kubernetes
logging tool that's super helpful and
that you can use regular expressions to
exclude certain types of logs and yet
you can also select based on deployment
so you don't actually need the the pod
name which can be annoying to copy/paste
so what I can see here is um is a whole
bunch of output on the weather back-end
side but if I do a bunch of like page
refreshes what I want to be seeing is is
a report that we did a successful
request and I'm not seeing that so it's
just a whole month's a bunch of other
sort of cleanup and mixer logs so that's
not super helpful I'll keep that open in
case I need it later so what I want to
see next if we think back at that kind
of architecture for EM TLS and how to
enable it there are two is Co control
plan components we need to check in on
the first is pilot the second is mixer
with pilot what we want to make sure is
that pilot is taking our configuration
and pushing it down to the data plane so
what I will do here and sorry again for
this kind of spammy logs is that there
is there are policies that that pilot is
picking up and sending down and you'll
notice here in this log pilot conflict
outbound listener TCP 443 which is the
TLS poor proxy weather back-end single
okay but right now we kind of only care
about weather back-end multiple and this
can be kind of tough to sort of sort of
grep but we can see okay here's multiple
this might seem okay
about pilot conflict outbound listener
that seems bad but I'm not totally sure
like what it means so at this point I
can either sort of panic or kind of
think about the other components right
so there's said the Delta it's like okay
maybe there's something going wrong with
said they'll maybe the certs and keys
are not there and maybe it's like a
really quick fix so what I will next do
is make sure that Citadel is healthy
said that I was running that's good
but does that mean that the keys inserts
are there so what I will typically do is
this long command and I'm copy pasting
it because it's a bit long but what this
is doing is it's exacting into each of
our front end and back end pods
respectively and checking the validity
of those certs and keys so I'm going to
do that so the front end we can see that
we have a valid cert that it is the
valid times are valid and we can do the
same for the back end all right so my
hypothesis that maybe something was
weird with the certs and keys is kind of
not true that part seems to be okay so
now what you might be wondering what
would like what else would envoy be able
to report back to us that would be
helpful and what I'm about to do might
sound crazy but I'm actually going to
increase the log level and envoy to
debug from the fall info to see if on
boy can say anything more about why
requests to the backend are failing so
in order to do that
envoy so when you have an envoy
container it actually exposes an admin
console it's actually a UI I'm not going
to show it today but there's some
helpful stuff in there and you can send
requests to that admin console to to do
things with that very specific envoy
proxy so when I'm going to show here is
calling that admin console to enable
trace level logs for only the backend so
you can see here across all of Envoy
loggers I've just up to the log level to
trace and so what we hopefully will
start to see here is if I now refresh
this page a whole bunch more
which is yeah interesting there's a
whole bunch of logs that are coming in
you can see it's now like debug level
and it's like okay how do I even parse
this and there are a lot of ways to do
it just for purposes of this demo I'm
going to do a grep because I ran in this
demo before and I know what I'm looking
for and to do a grep on the word
handshake so if something went wrong
with the exchanging of certs and keys
during that initial TLS handshake error
whoops I have to export that pod don't I
we should we might see be seeing a TLS
handshake error so you'll notice that in
the last couple of seconds we got a
whole bunch of these debug logs from
envoy that are saying external envoy SSL
handshake error one so what this would
tell me if I enable them TLS is that the
very first step of that TLS connection
happening that very first step failed
and I know I have valid certs and keys
from the Envoy proxies so I know that
can't be it
so typically at this point I start to
blame myself what did I do wrong on the
config side to make this horribleness
happen so what I will do is go into all
of the resources that I added and try to
wrack my brain oh gosh what went wrong
so remember at the very beginning to
make all of this break we added a policy
one and a destination rule to what is
responsible for this for each of these
components so the policy is for the
server side destination rule for the
client side I will now use the SCO CTL
tool to try to figure out if there is a
conflict going on in my configuration so
Sandeep showed the SCO CTL command for
traffic routing I'm going to show the
same command-line tool but just a
different command which is
authentication TLS check and what this
does is compares the destination rule
and the policy for one service to see if
there is a conflict and let me get this
a little bit better so what we see here
for weather back-end so I called this
this command for just the weather
back-end what we see here is status
conflict server and TLS
client HTTP that's not what NLCS is
right what we hope to see is server MT
LS client and TLS so what's happening
here what this tells me is that roughly
if we go back to these resources
destination rule is what tells clients
of the weather back-end to use TLS this
is the problem this is where I am at
this point I'm like okay there's
something up with my destination rule
what do I do
so at this point what I will do is run
coups ETL get destination rule and see
oh gosh no I have to destination rules
for the same service this is not good in
this do you do not want overlapping
destination rules that say different
things so what I'll do at this point is
see what's actually going on there so
I'm getting those two destination rules
and I'm just gonna show the whole yeah
Mel output so we see both of the
destination rules here this is the one I
added right so dr weather back-end is
the one i added just a few moments ago
and this one is good enforce estilo
mutual this is what I expect to see I
scroll down I see the second destination
rule that was added by somebody probably
me an hour ago that said actually
traffic policy TLS mode disabled so at
this point envoy is very confused in
that it thinks it needs to be doing TLS
and not TLS at the same time 503 that's
kind of an oversimplification of like
what's actually happening under the hood
but what we would do to fix this is we
would delete the destination room that
we added before destination rule it's a
long word to type and we would modify
the destination rule we already had
surprise it was in here this one oops
lost it
that said TLS mode disabled we would
modify that to enable M TLS on it so I
have a file that does exactly that it's
here I'm going to apply it to my cluster
and what we hope to see crossing fingers
is that we can get back to the back end
so this doesn't show every single piece
of the debugging MCLs but I hope it kind
of shed some light about like how not to
enter a complete and total state of
panic when things go wrong on that end
so if we can go back to the slides
please thank you that was just the back
up video all right so let's wrap up a
little bit what did we learn in this
talk we only had a certain amount of
time so we did kind of have to pick and
choose the demos that we that we did but
what things that we looked at is like
how to determine if a virtual service is
actually working how to use a co CTL and
the Envoy logs to and and other tools to
really dig into what's happening sounded
showed us how to diagnose missing
missing metrics in Prometheus and
finally I just showed transport level
authentication here is a short and a
honestly abridged list of some of the
stuff we we used in this in this talk
this is not every single tool that you
can use to diagnose sto we know that the
tools ecosystem is locking and we are
talking about it and it is something
that we are extremely aware of in a
perfect world I never use curl to
diagnose when stos going wrong we need
something a little bit more scalable
right if the promise of ISTE o is
automation and being able to manage
hundreds or thousands of micro services
we need something better than curl so
I'm super excited for like the coming
months and years and the growing
ecosystem that is sto this is not the
end if you are still here for the rest
of the day there are multiple other sto
talks including vm mesh expansion CI CD
stuff with SEO as well as a discussion
of traffic director if that's of
interest to you a quick call out that we
are conducting user studies in the
coming months for SEO if you would like
to join these user studies you can grab
that QR code or go to that link our UX
team would love your feedback and your
participation thank you so much
[Music]